[Musique]
bonsoir barras mille mercis à d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france le
rapport du rapporteur de l'onu qui
déclare donc que l'unique chance de
développement pour gaza serait la fin du
blocus mis en place par israël est ce
que vous partagez vous cette analyse
oui bonsoir effectivement enfin il n'y a
pas de surprise je dirais dans ses
déclarations du rapporteur de l'onu
l'onu a nous a rappelé très
régulièrement à travers les temps le
fait que la situation d'occupation
prévalant dans les territoires
palestiniens d'ailleurs pas seulement à
gaza mais au niveau également au niveau
de la cisjordanie et quelque chose de
problématique
il n'y a pas de développement possible
sans occupation est de surcroît une
situation de blocus fait que bien
entendu l'asphyxient est totale
concernant concernant les territoires
palestiniens et concernant gaza en
particulier mais je vais dire que ce que
je suis en train de vous dire là
j'aurais pu vous le dire en 2007 en 2008
ou en 2010 c'est là qu'on a un problème
de fond dans les évolutions palestinian
c'est que non seulement la situation de
blocus est problématique mais de
surcroît le fait qu'on n'ait pas la
reconnaissance d'une entité étatique
effective qui puisse respirer qu'ils
puissent développer ses infrastructures
qui puisse réorienter ses politiques et
ses choix économiques est quelque chose
qui fait que de toute façon on pourra en
reparler dans un an dans deux ans dans
cinq ans dans dix ans tant que cette
situation d'occupation perdurera bien
sûr donc clairement ça passe par la
solution à deux états enfin il ya
beaucoup de théories en la matière mais
je crois que la solution je ne suis pas
partisan de la solution d'un état
binational je crois qu'effectivement il
y a un droit de droit international qui
continue à prévaloir même si sa mise en
application est compliqué je n'en
disconviens pas mais on est quand même
dans une situation dans laquelle les
paramètres de base sont des paramètres
étatique c'est à dire que l'onu avait
reconnu en novembre 1947 laquelle
l'existence ou la question de la
création d'un état palestinien à côté
d'un état israélien est depuis lors
l'histoire a été ce qu'elle a été mais
il n'en demeure pas moins que oui si on
ne crée pas deux états l'un à côté de
l'autre on serait en train d'annuler au
bien la notion de nation israélienne
la notion des rations palestinienne au
bien même ces deux là et ces deux
notions et donc en l'occurrence on
serait complètement hors champ
d'application du droit international d
de ce qu'il retient broquères en
l'occurrence en matière de droit des
peuples à l'autodétermination l'onu
effectivement qui intervient qui donne
cet avis clairement sur cette question
mais quelle est la marge de manoeuvre
est mon réel de l'institution
aujourd'hui
alors là on est dans un problème
constant c'est à dire que bien entendu
ce qu'ils peuvent faire la différence au
niveau de l'onu ce sont les cinq membres
permanents de l'onu et on est quand même
dans un contexte dans lequel l'on voit
bien que le veto d'un des états suffit à
bloquer toute avancée en ce sens c'est à
dire que si au contraire on organise et
maintenant un vote au niveau de
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
la donne serait complètement différente
et elle est on va dire que les les votes
abondant en faveur de la création d'un
état palestinien ne ferait pas de doute
à mon sens donc oui il y a un problème
de fonctionnement où il ya du moins un
blocage dû au fonctionnement à la nature
du fonctionnement de l'onu il y avait on
entendu un ascendant américain qui
oriente quand même désolé des évolutions
dans va dans le sens qui est celui qu'il
est aujourd'hui je crois qu'à
l'administration trump n'a pas beaucoup
amélioré les choses en ce sens là mais
ce n'est pas pour autant je crois que
avec l'entrée en vigueur de
l'administration de biden
il faudra s'attendre à des
développements vraiment révolutionnaire
sur la question je crois que
malheureusement il faut les palestiniens
prennent beaucoup leur mal en patience
mais on voit mal quelles sont les
horizons qui permettrait la mise en
application des principes rappelés par
l'onu dans la réalité des choses oui bah
justement c'était ma ma prochaine
question vous n'y croyez pas justement à
un tournant avec l'arrivée de joe biden
au niveau de cette politique justement
très honnêtement je crois que les
orientations de l'administration
américaine qu'elle était et est sous une
présidence démocrate ou sous une
présidence république elles n'ont pas
beaucoup fait de différence concernant
la situation socio économique des
palestiniens déjà et concernant la
possibilité de se pencher
de plus près sur la possibilité de
négociations politiques et je tiens à
rappeler quand même que bien sûr les
accords d'oslo avait eu lieu sous le
démocrate bill clinton mais que ces
mêmes big.little lui-même qui finalement
avait créé une situation plutôt
problématique pour yasser arafat à
l'époque à une époque où il avait essayé
de rapprocher les points de vue de
yasser arafat et du premier israélien de
l'époque ehud barak avant que de trahir
finalement il ya sert arafat et je ne
crois pas que sous barack obama on ait
eu beaucoup de d'initiative au beaucoup
d'avancées ont même beaucoup
d'insistance sur la nécessité de créer
deux états l'un à côté de l'autre
ajoutons à cela le fait que bayonne est
quand même engagé maintenant parler on
va dire par les déclarations et qui ont
été prises ou par l'epa qui ont été pris
par donald chante notamment concernant
la question de jérusalem est donc en ce
sens là je ne vois absolument pas de
possible retour en arrière et je donc je
crois que au delà de la rhétorique qui
pourrait être peut-être être plus
aimable concernant l'application je
crois que non le liens
américano-israéliens restera extrêmement
fort et restera plutôt orienté aux
conditions israéliennes
merci beaucoup barah mikaïl à directeur
de strategy consulting professeur à
l'université saint louis à madrid
d'avoir été avec nous pour vu de
l'extérieur ce soir